(playful music)
- Most people don't think too
much about changing the world,
but here, we do.
Right, Joey?
Here at SynDaver Labs in Tampa,
Florida, we make the world's
most sophisticated synthetic
human tissues and body parts.
(playful music)
Just take a look at Joey here.
While he might look like a real boy,
he's actually a synthetic cadaver.
He's made to breathe, bleed
and act just like a real human.
Joey leads an incredibly interesting life.
High-five, Joey.
All this technology he and
and his friends are made of
allow them to replace
cadavers, live animals
and even human patients.
A synthetic human takes
about three weeks to build
from start to finish.
They're very difficult to build,
there are thousands of parts.
If you just look at the
job of assembling one,
it's staggeringly difficult.
It takes six specially
trained teams to make Joey.
Skeletal,
skin,
muscles,
organs,
vasculature,
and final assembly.
And then there's our
tech crew, engineering,
electronics and tooling.
Everything that we make
has to be stored in water
when it's not being used
because it's made, you know,
primarily of water just
like a every living thing.
You know, there's always a
high demand for real cadavers.
The supply is limited.
They're getting tougher
and tougher to get.
And with our synthetic cadavers,
what we're really mimicking is
live tissue not dead tissue,
so the experience you get
is more like the experience
you would get with a live
body than a dead body.
SynDaver technology is
definitely improving the way
people study medicine,
study medical procedures,
study medical device development
because it makes the whole system better.
It allows surgeons to train in procedures
that they would not be able to train in
without risking a patient.
While we'll never know
how Joey spends his time
after we go home and turn the lights off.
We do know that once he
moves into his forever home,
he'll be training people to save lives.
Atta boy, Joey!